today we will be explaining all of
nezuko's forms in demon slayer we will
start with her human form and in the
later parts of the video we'll explain
her most powerful demonic forms we all
know nezuko as tonjiro's younger sister
and one of the main characters in the
show she is also one of the most unique
characters in the entire demon slayer
world while spending most of the time
hidden in a specially made box she would
often be very helpful and save tonjero's
life on many occasions but before
becoming the powerful demon she is today
she was once a regular human while we
don't know much about her human life we
know for certain that she was a good and
caring person nezuko grew up on a
mountain alongside her older brother
tonjiro the rest of her siblings and her
mother as the eldest daughter of the
commodo family she presumably took care
of her younger siblings as an assistant
to her mother as is briefly witnessed
prior to her family's death unlike
tangero who was responsible for selling
firewood in town nezuko would usually
help out around the family home after
the demon king muzan kibutsuji found and
attacked the comodo family while tantro
was out in the village nezuko was the
only one left alive she was then turned
into a demon by muzon's blood now things
are getting interesting keep watching so
you don't miss some of her most powerful
forms number 4. demon form as a demon
nezuko seems to have forgotten a good
portion of her memories as a human
besides those related to her family and
thus doesn't retain the exact
personality she had before the
transformation as soon as she regained
her consciousness as a demon she
attacked her brother tanjro who was
carrying her on his back soon after she
recognized her brother and started
crying proving that she still possesses
her human side when giyu tamayoka
charged towards tonjiro she jumped in to
protect him showing you and everyone
else that she is a different type of
demon giu realized this and decided not
to slay nezuko but instead send her and
tanjuro to his former teacher tsukonji
urukudaki as the chosen demon nezuko has
several unique demonic traits that set
her apart from all other demons most
notably nezuko can continuously restore
her power without consuming any humans
like all other demons would need to do
instead she recovers her strength
through sleep alone though she would
have to spend a lot of time sleeping in
order to recuperate and regain her power
upon being transformed into a demon
nezuko displayed the basic ability to
change and alter her body's size and
height she was able to shrink herself
into the physical size of a small child
in order to fit inside a small box or a
basket in order to hide from sunlight
during the night if her brother needed
any help she would often enlarge herself
into a much bigger form in order to be
able to battle against demons number 3
demon combat form as a demon nezuko
possesses naturally enhanced physical
strength even at the start of the series
when she first became a demon she was
strong enough to decapitate another
demon with a single kick her most
prominent trait is her extraordinary
growth rate possibly due to the high
amount of blood she received from muzon
and the fact that she doesn't need to
consume humans to stay alive nezuko
punched the swamp demon so hard that he
coughed up blood even overwhelming the
demon with powerful punches and kicks as
she has no combat experience nezuku
relies on brute strength using her legs
as her main weapon to deliver fast and
strong kicks this was shown across many
battles during the course of the series
where she would defeat her enemies
despite being overwhelmed by them in the
beginning neziko is often seen using her
extraordinary growth technique in the
middle of the battle gaining incredible
power boosts this is best exemplified
during her battle against susumaru where
her foot was blown by the demon's ball
attack but after regenerating she was
able to face her in an even match
kicking the ball and eventually
surpassing her she has been shown to
defeat her enemies by increasing her own
physical capabilities enhancing her
regeneration or developing her own blood
demon art in dire situations her
self-made blood demon art is called
pyrokinesis it allows her to generate
and manipulate special demonic flames
created from her blood nezuko can do
this by igniting her blood or creating
it from thin air her flames have a
special property that makes them only
harmful to demons and objects of demon
origin while being completely harmless
to humans and other objects this was
shown when her fire could burn rui's
threads and moo's dream spell and
genya's demon form but was unable to
affect tandro and the mugen train her
flames have been noted to hamper the
regeneration of demons to an extent as
shown with daki being temporarily unable
to regenerate from being burned by her
flames nezuko has shown to be quite
proficient in using her blood demon art
from setting demons on fire to enhance
the potency of her attacks burning off
gyeo taro's poison to save enosuke and
tenjin and turning tanjaro's nichiren
sword bright red which gave him a much
needed advantage against tantangu's
clones number 2 awakened form nezuko's
awakened form is her most powerful
combat form she has the ability to enter
into a berserk state where she becomes
more demonic in appearance transforming
into an adult version of herself with
vine like tattoos that circle her body
and a horn protruding from her right
forehead side this awakened form greatly
enhances nezuku's physical capabilities
as well as increases her regeneration
level to match that of the upper ranked
demon at the cost of her needing to feed
on human blood the first time nezuku
uses her awakened form is against upper
rank six ducky when transformed the mere
pressure emanating off of her made doki
afraid for her life with no hesitation
nizuko dashes towards the upper rank and
delivers a powerful downward kick daki
in response cuts her leg and tries to
behead her however nezuko still lands a
solid blow on doki's back smashing her
into the ground this comes as a surprise
to donkey as to how did a disembodied
leg still land a kick to which she
discovered that as she cut nazuku's leg
it regenerated quick enough for her to
still attack thus making her admit that
nezuko's regeneration surpassed hers
completely daki cuts all of nezuko's
body with her sashes while nezuko's
right arm catches one of them despite
being severed from her body she realizes
that nezuko solidified her own blood in
order to stop the impact from her sash
without daki realizing it nezuko
converts her solidified blood into her
blood demon art and engulfs docky with
crimson red flames
as the upper rank continues to burn and
scream from anguish and terror nezuko
reassembles her amputated limbs and her
head giving off a sadistic smile and
stomps docky's head into the ground
despite usually being able to control
her bloodlust in this form it seems that
nezuko has a hard time doing that after
seeing human blood due to her
transformation drastically increasing
her demonic instincts she quickly dashes
at the woman to eat her and consume her
blood tanjuro springs to action and
stops nizuko by restraining her body
with his legs and covering her mouth
with his nichiren sword jaki reappears
with the right side of her body
including her face badly burned from
nezuko's blood demon art on top of this
despite being a demon specifically an
upper rank her regeneration speed has
significantly waned due to nezuko's
flames which is another testament to how
strong her power really is when tenjin
arrives he points out to tonjro that his
sister is flamboyantly progressing into
a real demon losing her humanity in the
process it's important to state that
nezuko has all this power without ever
devouring a single human which brings us
to the question how powerful could she
become if she started consuming human
blood could she become one of the
strongest upper ranks let us know what
you think in the comments number one
chosen demon despite being a young demon
neziko has displayed great combat
proficiency and skill in battle
overpowering many strong demons nezuko's
accelerated growth also seems to mirror
tangero's own incredible growth rate as
she could take on members of the 12
kazuki and match upper ranked demons in
months however the trait that sets her
apart from all other demons is the fact
that she has the ability to conquer the
sun prompting the demon king to call her
the chosen demon during the battle
against upper rank 4 hontengu nezuko
developed immunity from sunlight a feat
impossible even for the demon lord
himself with this immunity she is able
to walk and go about in the daytime
without being burnt to ash prompting
luzon to shift his goals to hunt and
absorb her to conquer the sun himself
click on this video where we explained
all of tonjiro's forms in demon slayer
don't be shy click it